Time for audience questions submitted throughout
the week, uh, by the audience.
Let me know what you want
need to address on the show.
First question is, Hey David, is Bernie's
anti endorsement list a good idea or will
it backfire?
So let me tell you what this is.
First, Bernie Sanders put out a list, not
of people who have endorsed him, but if people
who have said don't vote for Bernie Sanders,
uh, this is a list of a bunch of prominent
billionaires.
There are Wall Street bankers on the list.
There are some big corporate CEOs who have
said, Bernie's a disaster.
Don't vote Bernie.
Bernie's policies are terrible.
So this could be both the, you know, the question
is, is it a good idea or will it backfire?
It can both be a good idea that backfires.
I mean, that's sort of the idea of, of a backfire,
which is something that is a good idea.
Ends up something ends up not going as planned.
It ends up actually being counterproductive.
So there's a bunch of people on this list
that are relatively notable.
One that comes to mind to me is billionaire
cofounder of Home Depot, Kenneth Langan, who
is a known big Trump booster.
A Disney CEO, Bob Iger is on the list.
JP Morgan Chase, CEO, Jamie diamond is on
the list.
So the idea here is the enemy of my enemy
is my friend.
It's sort of the idea here, which is um, uh,
that if you see a or enemy of the of my enemy
is my friend in reverse sort of thing.
The idea being if you see that a lot of these
big corporate multinational CEOs or whoever
don't like Bernie and you see the goals of
the, those same CEOs and billionaires as not
aligned with what you want, you might say
the fact that these CEOs and Wall Street bankers
don't like Bernie, uh, suggest to me that
Bernie does have my best interest in Bernie's
Po in mind and Bernie's policies would be
what's best for me and I am going to support
Bernie because these people don't like Bernie.
It's a perfectly fine and reasonable idea.
Uh, I think that the risk is of being couched
as being against rich people.
And this is also a thing where, is it a badge
of honor or is it not a badge of honor?
Joe Biden famously a couple of weeks ago was
caught saying to a group of big donors, listen,
I don't think we should really hurt the rich.
I don't think you're bad people.
I'm not going after you.
Nothing is substantively going to change for
you.
If I become president of the United States.
We're going to deal with some things sort
of around the edges and that's going to be
it.
Bernie's taking a different approach.
Bernie is saying, oh no, I am going to change
things for a lot of these big corporate CEO's
and for Wall Street bankers.
He's outlined some of the policies that would
do that.
Raising taxes on the rich financial transactions,
taxes that would eat away at some of the Wall
Street profits in order to take that money
and use it for useful social programs and
other kinds of economically stimulative spending.
And the idea is that's good stuff.
Bernie is saying things aren't going to be
so good for these corporate CEOs and bankers.
That makes me like Bernie and I'm going to
vote for him.
Now here's my bottom line opinion on this.
I think it doesn't matter.
Okay.
I don't think endorsements matter very much
and in the same way, I don't think anti endorsements
very, very matter very much.
It's fine that Bernie did this.
It's possible that it will have some net positive
benefit to be perfectly frank, I just don't
think many voters are either going to vote
for Bernie or not on the basis of whether
the home depot CEO Likes Bernie or doesn't
like Bern.
I just don't think it matters.
I truly don't, and there has been over time
more and more consensus that endorsements
really do not matter that much other than
there are some really specific things that
make a difference.
Sitting presidents going around and saying,
I endorse x candidate and they are who should
take over for me and I'm going to aggressively
campaign for them.
There is still the idea that that matters
didn't work out for Hillary Clinton with Barack
Obama, but in general there's the idea that
that can make a difference.
Celebrity endorsements not really moving the
needle.
Big political endorsements doesn't really
seem to make much of a difference.
So I actually find myself thinking that it's
fine for Bernie to do this.
There is a small enclave of the electorate
that may be influenced by this big picture.
I don't think it's going to do much more for
him one way or the other.
Let me know what you think.
If you disagree with me, if you think that
Bernie's anti endorsement list will move the
needle in some way, could be for the better,
could be for the worst.
Uh, let me know.
I want to hear from you.